JOING  FRO
I TAND YOU GOT HARROWI
LOOK AT THE FRONT LINES OFS
WAWHAT YOU SAW.
>>H,Y D,
O
OUL OF THOSE LG ANCE STRIKES TH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
COBUT OUE
FO AISOME OE RUTAL
POUNDING THE TOWN, WHICH
WANT TO TAKE FROM E
UKRAINIANS, HOWEVER, THE
UKRAINIANS AREOL
HERE IS WHAT W
WHEN ENTER NEED IS FOR
SPEED.
'R INTO ONE OSPLACES I
WAR TORNKRAINE WITH A MIAT MEDS
CALL SIGN  USA. UNDER CONSTANT
ASSAULT.OUR CAR SN TT WHEN THE S
>> WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
>> Reporter:VE
ARTILLERY FIRE.
WE'LL WAIT A HOPE THERAR
HITS CLOSEUS
RECEIVING END OF A FULL RUSSIAN
ARTILLERBARRAGE.ONS]
>> Rr: PHOTOALISTS
PRTIR OUR OW TRACKS SEVE
>> Reporter: UKRAI OELSES A
>> Translator: THE ARTILLERY
TAERY DAIEOTR ITY TAKETS MANY T
THERE WHENIN
>> HUSBAND WAS
E  H
GREA
FIGHTERSM THPRIVATE NYST DOWN W
AR OVERHYS HER CONNC
SH.
>> Translator: ABSOLUTELIN PRIF
CIVILIANS ARE DYIN
>> Reporter:HE FIGHTINMU AND
LEE THATAI
ANYMORRTILLE ERGEISNCO
I ASK HIM IF HE'.
VLADIMIR PUTIN'SORCES.CITY FROM
I  ONE THING, WOLF, THAT
UKRAINIAN COMBAT MEDIC DIDEVEN
SHELLS WERE COMING AND SHE
THE REASON WS THEY FACE THIS
EVDAY.RAINIANS SAY RHT Y'RE IISY
IS VERY DIFFBU IVE UP A SINGLE
BOTH RUSSIAN
US.
FRED IE  FOR
FOR MOREE WAR IN U
T' TOP ADVISOR TO T IGOR.
LOTIN ME IS PUTIN'ING US.
FOR UKRAINICCUPIED AREAS,
SOHEMADEDVANCES?
>> Y KNOW, A
T  DESPAIR FROM PUTIN.
I ME ABSOLY ON THE BATTLE ND
'S TRYINTORUMI TERRITORIESN TER.
THE UKRAINIAN CITIZENS STILL
TERRITORIES
D SIGNLA TS SO-CALLED
W MEAN IT MIGHT N G THE
HUN RILE.
ITIGR PREPARATION
FOR AN
TH
TEMPORARY OCCUPIEDA IN
2014WHE
PTDY MAG TO MAKE IN TPIED KHERS
IANS ARE LEAVING
ERD 1500LREADY B
SO I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IOR US,OR
NOTHINS MOVING D
UKRAINE. TOP UE L Y TH  REGIONSO
OFFICIAL SAYES KEYY OF
.
YOU THAT'IBLE?
ABOUT ANS SINCE THE
WAR.
NIE ACTIVITIES OF D FORCES ARE T
THE REIGN ISLT.
TH ABSOLUTELT ELAGVEHICLES I SHO
NACOPROVIDUSUILT
FE IS
ILE ATTACKH
ARTILLERY AND VEHICLES
ANT
COUNTER REGIONS
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HASTHLLL
NERAEL S'T BUDGE ORE SS
ON DOME SYSTEM AND
ELP UKRAINE WARNING EM
INSTEAO TE?
>> IT'S TOO LITTLE TTE.RTATA PO
GOVERNMENT OF ISNDELE
Y  TTEMENTS, WHICH
L OFFICIALS HAS MADE JUS
RECENTLY AUTUSATISFACTORY, IT CL
THEY'RE G
TOD
EL ISN'T THE ONLY COUNY
PRE
SYSTEMWE THED PRODUCING FEE S T
EUROPEANNI COUNTRIES SO ER
ON THIT TO
PRECSKY OFT AN
DEFENSE B
LONG RANGE AND
MIDDLEPROTEC